el parlamento europeo ha rechazado por
primera vez y de forma simbólica el
acuerdo de la unión europea con los
países de mercosur
los eurodiputados con 345 votos a favor
consideran que el pacto no se puede
aprobar en su forma actual debido a la
política medioambiental del presidente
de brasil y jair bolsonaro este aviso se
ha producido a través de una enmienda
promovida por el partido del presidente
francés emmanuel macrón en la eurocámara
es un aviso sin embargo que no es la
primera vez que se produce ya se ha
producido en otros parlamentos
nacionales como en el de austria países
bajos o francia que también han
rechazado este pacto se trata sin
embargo de votos totalmente simbólicos
pero con una importante carga política a
pesar de que este acuerdo comercial no
se va a ratificar hasta mínimo de aquí a
dos años a pesar de todo este acuerdo
comercial siempre ha estado rodeado de
muchísima polémica tras 20 años de
larguísimas negociaciones debido a las
reticencias que tiene por las
consecuencias que puede tener para los
agricultores europeos y también para los
países del blog
y americano